oh [ __ ] you good timing though I mean oh
yes no thank you I don't want any please
go away
I would rather not I've dealt with
millet or any way I can
you didn't hear [ __ ]
Jesus balls
is there a little baby crying I guess is
where they burn all the bodies do not
look more like more Santa that was new
don't have a lot of job ha ha oh that
scared me worse than that skull ah run
run
aah what the hell are you that was
stupid
I'm a big baby I cry like a baby
[Music]
what does yeah Kyle you die no thank you
okay
ah what is this parlor key ah ah [ __ ]
you give me up I'm out there what what
what no no yes no running come on one oh
Jesus balls [ __ ] off hey why didn't I
get any warnings oh that's a chair I
thought I saw something else in the
darkness god damn it [ __ ] you
oh yeah I'm a sphere in this game was
very very very oh I saw something in the
darkness is something wrong with Susan
don't turn around
[Music]
where are you sweetie honey can move
this prisoner was too stupid to put it
in the furnace ha ha good way go hey oh
this this place is ah who are you where
to go why oh come on bunny didn't even
get close to me [ __ ] that [ __ ]
everything about that then no no no
[Music]
no this has been the random horror
reaction compilation thanks for watching
if you liked what you saw and you want
to see more why not subscribe to my
channel want to help the channel grow
please leave a like add it to your
favorites or share it with your friends
on Facebook and Twitter thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]